after an explosive start in round eight
the candidates were back to continue
their quest to become the next
challenger in the hunt for the world
championship title
pre-event leader maxine bashir lagrave
survived almost certain doom to make a
draw against ding loren
while dutch superstar anish geary
defeated wang hao in style
and now stands in a three-way tie for
second just a half point off the lead
it's the round before the rest day and
the players will be jockeying for
position
round 10 coverage of the candidates in
yekaterinburg russia
starts now
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome everybody to round ten of the
candidates
we are here bringing you the action that
is taking place
in yakaterenburg russia and
what a tournament it has been so far
a year wait between rounds seven and
eight
but what a worthy wait it was we've had
so much drama
in the last couple of days it feels like
we filled up
a full tournament worth of it my name is
alejandro ramirez i am here
with grand masters maurice ashley and
yasser sarah juan
to bring you all the action of today's
rounds yasser
what a tournament so far indeed it has
been just that
uh the weight has been worthwhile
i'll put it like that alejandro we
waited a year and
boy has the tournament started with the
bank fabiano in our opening round won a
must-win game
and yesterday we saw an emergence of the
dutch
champs on each geary so
everything to play for suddenly as we
have a clear separation
of the top half and the bottom half
maurice it's been
it's been fun really has been even with
the long days long games especially
on the first day we saw two victories
that really shook up the tournament
and it's great to see four players in
the hunt we started the tournament
remember
with two players separating themselves
dramatically a full point
from the rest of the pack but now it's
all bunched up a half a point
only separating the leader from the
trailing trio
so it's it promises to be an exciting
next five rounds guys and today is a big
one before the rest day they usually go
all out
let's take a look at the standings
alejandro you can see
jane pognachi the russian player up
there with
five and a half points out of nine he is
the current leader and he wants to hold
on to that lead
desperately because you mentioned it
that trailing trio they're hungry
and they're dangerous maxima sharla
grabs surviving by a miracle yesterday
against dinglery but sometimes you need
that little bit of luck
to make it to the very top of the event
fabiano caruana with five points you
mentioned that incredibly
important victory that he got himself
against mvl
in round one of the second part of the
round robin
meanwhile yesterday was all about anish
giri he won against warhaw and puts
himself
half a point away from first place and
that distance between the top half and
the second half
it's grown one how alexander griswold
and krill alexenko
all on minus one four out of nine that's
gonna be difficult for them
to challenge for the first place but
they're still trying and of course
the very surprising bottom of the
tournament is held by dingleren
many people gave him a nod before the
tournament started
as a potential challenger to magnus
carlson but if that is to happen
i think it's gonna have to wait at least
a couple more years because
he just doesn't have enough points this
time around
let's take a look at the format of the
event a double round robin the first
half was played last year
the second half is just started 100
minutes for the first 40 moves it's real
classical chess
so you get another 50 minutes for the
next 20
and once you reach move 60 you'll get
yet another 15 minutes and this is
actually not the most common
time control and many times even in this
time control 15 minutes
are not uh really added because most
games don't last until 60.
but man we've seen a lot of long games
in this second half
of the double round robin don't forget
there's a 30 second
increment all throughout the game and no
draw offers before black's 40th move
fighting chess for sure
500 000 euro prize fund but nobody cares
about that
everybody wants that ticket to the world
championship
in dubai and the schedule we have
a game today and tomorrow we will have
our very first
rest day and they will continue with the
format of two games
and the rest day we have games on the
23rd and the 24th a rest day after that
and then the 26th and the 27th to finish
off the tournament
the unlikely scenario in which we do
have playoffs because
all the mathematical tiebreaks are still
equal would happen
on the 28th but as i mentioned that is
actually rather unlikely but we've
mentioned it there's the top half and
the bottom half maurice what's been
going on with the players there at the
top
pardon me there we have the fantastic
four and
this foursome is simply amazing i mean
they are showing
that they're the big dogs of chess the
best of the best
actually any one of these would excite
us if they were to play a match
against magnus carlson let's start with
maxim
bashir lagrave maxine the frame the
fabulous frenchman
he has shown himself to be a very
mercurial one
indeed we saw him draw and win the first
two games then a bunch of draws and then
a win in round seven that was huge put
him in the
lead in the first half of the event that
is the mathematical lead
because he beat a co-leader but then
that loss in round eight
was ugly for him he tried to fight back
against that big novelty by caruana
couldn't hold it up and i got to tell
you you used the word miracle alejandro
but i draw in round nine that probably
is miracle square
i mean no way he should have saved
himself in that game he managed to stay
in the hunt
and now trying to keep the momentum at
least turn it around so that he can once
again
be in first place and speaking of
the player who defeated him fabiano
caruana
he started off the tournament also in
tepid fashion a draw then a win then a
loss in round three and then a series of
draws
before that big win in round eight
and then a draw in round nine he looks
like he could be in form guys
this is fabulous fabi after all we've
seen him win seven in a row
we'll never forget him doing that so
he's a dangerous customer
when he gets going we'll keep our eye on
him for someone to keep an eye on and
i'm sure
all the the fans in the netherlands are
thrilled to see
their boy aneesh geary rocking and
rolling now
he lost in round one usually when you do
that folks
it's goodbye you're not going to be
contending you're trying to become a
world champion
and losing in the first round but after
a number of steady draws in round six
he won a game and then finished the
first half and 50
but it was yesterday's round nine
against wang hao
that has everybody with their eyes open
now
for this superstar dutchman he
has shown that he is informed this year
at tata steel
he and his fellow dutchman were able to
win type of first place although he
didn't lose on a tie break
but absolutely in form and then he won
the magnus carlson
invitational a rapid event which simply
he is not known as a rapid specialist
his confidence seems to be growing by
the month
can he make it happen in this event and
prove his talent that he's shown from an
early age
to be actually realized and speaking of
talent yeah napolici nobody doubts the
talent
of this man the big russian superstar
as well he is simply the class of the
tournament right now
leading the event anyway he did lose one
game in round seven that's a big
loss but in the first half he had won
three out of six
can he get back to his winning ways he's
that kind of player folks
streaky as ever if he starts winning
watch out
and he's got a big opportunity this
round as a matter of fact
so he will try to extend that lead guys
i'm telling you this this one here is
dangerous today
could be a big day for him but for all
the players they'll be looking
to try to grab those points there's only
five rounds left
it's the sprint to the finish line thank
you maurice and let's take a look at the
pairings alejandro
we gotta start with that crucial matchup
between fabiano caruana and
dingleren it's true dingleran hasn't
been doing great but these
are the number two and number three
players
in the planet and you know that fabi
with the white pieces he's gonna be
hungry for a win
another crucial one mvl with the white
pieces against
anish giri both players with five points
that means that they're both
hungry for that victory they need to put
that pressure on your nephew
one hour against alexander grissock
perhaps not the most direct for the
standings both players a little bit
relegated
but it's still an interesting game
meanwhile wow
everything could be determined here yana
pomnyacci with five and a half points
he's playing his countryman
kiril alexenko it's true he did win
against alexander grisham he must be
very motivated
but alex senko is with the black pieces
he is the lower rated player
of the tournament and jan he has a
great opportunity here i think we got to
start
right there yasser why don't you just
take us directly
into the action absolutely it we're just
going to go back a few moves as the
round has been in progress
we get to this position
we get to this position and i just look
at the position and i say
oh my goodness white has an ideal
catalan look at this bishop on g2 in an
open cattle and an
unobstructed view down the long diagonal
all of white's pieces are developed
perfect harmony
this is what you want people when you
play a catalan
conversely on the other side of the
board look across the board
what's that rook doing on a8 that bishop
doing on c8
uh the only good news for carol
is he's not material down but as we
go forwards to the current position on
the board the last
move was this move bishop g5 and i tell
you when you look at this bishop
combined with the weakness of the square
d5
now that the pawn has been pushed to e5
bishop takes f6
knight d5 these types of moves play
themselves
and it's an enormous strategic
advantage again carol is not down
material
but i would be shocked if the computer
didn't say he's down two or three pawns
because the bishop on g2 is great this
rook on c1
well you can see this uh potential
uh pins uh on the c file
it's all gone wrong like this is not
what you want
as black in a carrot in a catalan
so nepal looking really good let's jump
to the
i want to point out sorry about that
game please karil has 14 minutes
ooh almost as bad wow as sasha
14 minutes 14 minutes if this game
is not over i don't know what is
yeah 23 moves wow 23 moves in 14 minutes
in a lost position
20 no 17 17
23 moves you got 14 minutes
for 23 moves in a lost position
good luck with that exactly crazy
uh fabiano and uh dinglerin
number two and number three in the world
just to remind everybody
in the first half of the event
uh ding liran did inflict a loss
on fabi and it was a
pretty theoretical affair right up to
here aleandro
and why don't you inform the people
about this position in particular
a position that i actually saw live on
the board
uh between one of my students dario
schwiertz representing america in the
world team championship
in astana he had this particular
position against guess what
dingleran himself and darius got a
winning position out of the opening but
was unable to finish off the chinese
superstar
and in that game um dinglan played the
move knight before
and he played the move a night before
two other times against grizzjerk and
against amin bassem
so dingleran an incredibly experienced
player in this kind of anti-martial
positions i think
him and aronian are by far the players
that know these positions the best but
fabi's saying i have ideas here
let me show you what i have and things
was like
no thank you i played knight before
enough maybe it's a good move but i'm
gonna switch it up play the move queen
c8
and that seemed to catch fabi by
surprise because he did take quite a bit
of time
finding the move bishop a3 a fascinating
move in this position
normally the pawn on a5 is just kind of
dead so you don't bother
really defending it and you play for
peace activity on the rest of the board
exactly what favi is doing dingleran
thought for a while perhaps
not very familiar with the move bishop
a3 or perhaps not expecting this
variation
at all and after knight takes a5 queen
c2
c5 we get this kind of wild position
e5 d takes e5 and white has many choices
actually you could take on e5
with uh the knight you could take on e5
with the pawn you could actually even
play knight
somewhere else and there is a lot of
complications but
five decided to take on c5 instead
keeping the position
on balance and you can imagine an
impractical approach
trying to win this game that is of
course what you want to do that being
said
black is upon he does have a blockade so
in a strategically complex position
harder to say who's better
i'm not even sure which side i'd prefer
to play with
you do have a pawn but your structure is
weak
c5 is both strong and weak because you'd
have to keep defending it
on the other hand if it reaches c6 it
might just be a thorn that you can never
get rid of
a fascinating position this one is going
to be strategically very interesting
absolutely well we'll leave it there as
unbalanced for sure
i do like white but we'll see how it
evolves uh
mvl let's turn to the game between mvl
and anish geary as two of the players
who are in the second position
uh fighting for the first place it was a
very theoretical
um variation of this feshnikov
that the move c5 it's it was discounted
some time ago it wasn't
considered that effective for a while
a couple of interesting things if we can
go back to the opening
because uh i'm actually quite familiar
with this position since i
prepared fabi for the world championship
match against magnus carlsen
and we obviously consider the move c5
and actually knight b8 is a little bit
out of fashion now
97 is considered to be a little bit more
uh
fashionable even though it is yeah yeah
it's a good it's a decent move
uh so a couple of surprises there anish
repeating this version cuff something
that's not really part of his repertoire
c4 uh comes in bishop e7
and c5 which is also quite rare
it used to be known as a slightly
annoying idea if you didn't know what
you were doing back in the early 2000s
but it was discounted kind of largely
because after c5 castles
black was supposed to be okay and there
were still some ideas but i don't know
if mbl had a new one
um and the game kind of goes on but
anish decided to play this very rare
move knight a6
showing that he's prepared in even these
sidelines
and after that moves pawn takes d6
we reach this position that really
doesn't seem like it is flashing off
black relinquishes the pair of bishops
but on the other hand
he gets to fight against this isolated
pawn on the
position of d5 and you can see that
black's gonna hammer at that guy with
everything he's got he even plays the
move b6 he's gonna play bishop b7 rook
d8
the position kind of plays itself but of
course white does have
enough resources and just about enough
resources to hold on to the pawn
uh the question is can you make any
headway after that or will the blockade
just be a little bit too annoying
again a position strategically
interesting
with different factors so not the
quality that we're used to
in a lot of these positions i think this
one has a lot of life to it
i'd also like to make the point when you
see the knight trade itself
for the dark square bishop and give
white the two bishops
you say well maybe white's doing well
there but knights are
famous for lifting blockading pieces
uh when you sit your queen on that d6
square
and you say well how are we going to get
rid of this queen and
it's not easy because you don't have a
knight white doesn't possess a night
anymore
you decided to get the two bishops for
it and so as you see the play
move along this queen is just laughing
on the square
you can't get rid of me if you try i can
just sit here
and then try to figure out how to hammer
as you said at the light square pawn
that white has to keep defending as
black can hit that pawn
with more minor pieces that attack light
squares than black actually owns you see
what that knight in bishop that black
has they can hit the d5 pawn but that g5
pawn can never protect it
so the question is really that imbalance
how are you going to get this
bishop on g5 how are you going to prove
this bishop wherever you put it
to be a real piece like this is my
advantage
is this bishop how am i gonna make it
get into the game so bishop g5
a little bit of an annoying move to make
sure rook d8 is not possible
and now the big question is how does
anish
actually gang up on this pawn on d5 some
more if he can't double rooks
if the bishop is sitting on h4 are we
going to see g5 happen
that'd be a lot maybe just f6 which of
course weakens
the light square diagonal i'm intrigued
this is a very strategically complex
position
absolutely as we were coming on air i
was
looking at this position and just to
your point maurice
queen on d6 really bothers me a lot and
yes i desperately would like to play the
move d5
d6 so the move that i was actually
thinking about and i was playing
around with it a lot was ideas of a4
and b3 in order to play the move bishop
a3 and to challenge
yeah and so it was a little bit
surprising for me to see this move
bishop g5
i was also surprised to see the move h6
i was actually thinking that black would
just play
f6 king h8 and say okay what is your
bishop going to do
you're probably going to bring it back
to e3 but
on each set h6 i'm fine bishop h4
now the big question is and help me out
here guys
is f7 f5 and g5 too ambitious
bold for sure f5 loses right because
bishop e7
uh that's a nice
move because it's a discovered check
too i think that's the end right because
i take that out
and calculate anything so i have to do
it in the other move order i have to
play g5 oh
am i again going to fall for a bishop
yes
i again fall for oh
nice okay well that's a tactic which
kind of okay let's let's just get our
king out of dodge
and again i'm thinking f5 and g5 but i
do apologize to the remaining game let
me jump
to that that's the game between wang hao
alexander grishock
look we understand that sasha he has a
time trouble problem
i mean it's the no drugs can
cure it we've tried everything folks
it's impossible he hasn't been moderner
and madonna have invented a vaccine to
solve
the time trouble problem that gristick
has that's exactly the point
he is consumed an hour and 41 minutes
for 11 moves that are all theoretical
i mean excuse me this is a french this
is a mainline
steinis french defense position it has
been reached
in grand master practice thousands of
games including the move g3
prepping for bishop h3 gift me the pawn
queen b6 queen d2 protecting the pawn
i mean they could have played this in a
bullet game
like these are all theoretical moves and
after the move knight
what we've just seen a very strange
recapture
knight f3 takes d4
uh i don't know what's going on with
sasha i mean this is
not it's so impractical guys it's just
it's just is it bad form is it uh
of insecurity it's chris jerk that's
what he does you know he's mentioned
over and over again that even in known
positions where he knows what he's
doing he just wants to look at the
position and make sure that he knows
the spirit he understands the concepts
but this one is kind of complicated i do
understand in some ways because there's
a lot of calculation to be done if
you're not familiar now after the move
queen d2 the position has been reached
twice
in grand master level play uh russian
grand masters fedocif and mirozevic
reached this position uh an interesting
clash of styles
because those are like two of the
craziest players uh the chess has ever
seen
uh in a good way they're incredibly
incredibly wild creatively
very original and kamsky reached it with
guess what
dingley ran with the black pieces back
in 2011
and it's a very complex position because
after c takes d4
you actually don't really want to
recapture
with the c pawn the reason being that
after c takes d4 you
kind of throw in this intermediate
bishop b4 knight c3
absolutely forced and then f takes e5
and you don't have a great way to
recapture
if you take with the d-pawn now that i
put your
knight on c3 i can go back to c5 and you
don't have enough control over d4 d4
actually being a threat
already so this is not amazing for white
would me
which means that you kind of have to
recapture with a knight on d4
and what happens then is that this
discovered attack
on uh the queen on b6 might become an
issue
you have to calculate if f takes e5
works some craziness for example
f takes knight takes e6 d4 and
that could be a roller coaster you can
imagine taking a long time trying to
calculate these variations and you have
to calculate it with both knights
because
both knight f takes d4 and knight e
takes d4
where possible i have to agree with you
yasser um knight e takes d4 looked a lot
more natural to me but perhaps there are
some concrete reasons
for why you want to take on d4 with the
f knight in this position
as wang hao has done well
in that one line where we had captured
the other way
in this case after the move d5 d4 if the
players do in fact go down this primrose
path
uh there is the move knight c3 a moment
ago the knight
was on f3 and we wouldn't be able to
block
the bishop so maybe there's some really
marvelous subtle reasons why you want to
take with it
f3 knight i just don't understand
how sasha could take so long to get to
this position
again he's got 15 minutes to the time
control let's again
jump quickly to our this is done
it's done it's over it's over
bishop e4 just easily wins now uh listen
when we
left it i mean guys nepa didn't break a
sweat in this game i mean
he has an hour and 20 minutes left i
mean
oh my goodness rook d1
knight d1 i i warned already that
watch out you're in a pin and
rook to d8 i guess the immediate b3
might run into some problem with
i don't know knight to d6 is a
possibility
nepal said wait a minute i've got a
different threat a
completely different idea i'm just going
to go
queen takes h7 check munch upon
decision i mean you can defensively yeah
you
uh this is a very well known uh pattern
where you you get this battery on the
diagonal
and you can't block the diagonal with
the move g6
the queen h7 bishop d3 yeah the problem
is the knight on c4 because it's not
really mate
you could play you could play h6 if you
don't want to give away a free pawn
sure after bishop e4 h6
okay i'm not giving away a pawn but that
tactic that you mentioned he has
with the knight going back to d6
attacking a queen
uh so what now the bishop
like this tactic at least i'm hitting a
queen but what if the queen disappears
what are you going to do then and bishop
to e4 is exactly first of all defending
the queen so
you could even go for the tactic now
probably b3
knight actually hear your name play
queen h7 i mean you're
yeah your knight is hanging so this
would not be necessary so just throw the
queen in on eight seven
as you pointed out alejandro and with
that check
that's the end of the story time to
resign
nothing to do guys and i'm gonna have to
say throughout this tournament the first
half of the candidates
i didn't think okay he's the best player
in the tournament but you can
say he can hang with everybody he was
having some good games
he put a lot of pressure on nepo himself
he came back in the second half and beat
grizzjerk
and i thought you know a lot of people
discounted him
and he showed he could hang but
man this one this one is
like for the critics right like what is
alex doing in this tournament
i would lose i would lose like this
against these guys but he's
super gm 2700 should not
in fact let's just say this this in
this single game is his worst game by
far yes
oh by far let's be real i don't think
you can play worse than this
and and anyone any self-respecting gm
goes down
like this you feel like what am i here
for like this is
this is crazy this is him just simply
forgetting
something about the opening and and and
we know we all
have horrible days this has got to be
one of the worst
games he's ever played or at least in
recent memory
that he's played and he's going to be uh
really disappointed
to have i think delivered like this in
such an event i think it's embarrassing
to play like this in the candidates
yeah i mean this is the kind this is the
kind of chance that
if a student came to me and brought me
this game i would have to say well
you need to play with all of your pieces
and the rook on a8 needs to develop and
the bishop on c8 needs to develop
what is this i mean he just got
completely crushed
yeah well he had a horrible horrible
opening right the cadillac
dream just happened instantly and you
have to point it out yeah as i think you
are now to show that
this had to happen very early well
exactly in these
catalans as black you really need to get
in this move
b5 and this move bishop e7 and
castles is just okay it looks good you
develop and you put your king
into safety but that's not what it's
about what it's about
is being able to challenge this long
diagonal
and black really needs to play the move
b5
and bishop b7 he can play bishop b5 and
bishop b7 and then
develop his king side he has no problem
so coming onto the show
uh alejandra and i were just discussing
queen
c7 followed by b5 as a way to get
uh developed and there are other lines
like here in this position
it without the move knight c3 they're
oops
even with the move knight c3 you can
play b5 immediately it is a line
yeah let's just i i just want to put up
a different kind of a line for a moment
the idea that you get to play b5 yes
knight can jump to e5 but then you block
the diagonal
so really um uh carol's
problems started very early
and it was these two i want to say
laxadaisical moves bishop e7
and castles that landed him in the in
trouble because
right here right now is the problem
you can't play b5 even if you wanted to
play rook
a7 then knight would just land on
c6 so before you know it
by the way bishop e3 was a good move and
again alejandro and i were
i was like pounding the table bishop f4
look at this alejandro e5 knight f5
again
a very nice advantage for white
something like that occurred anyway
bishop e3
knight b6 rook c1
and we got a situation well this is just
terrible
you gotta like what nippo did it was the
bishop e3 move that's the smooth move
right there
the point being he's saying your
position sucks i don't have to
do anything there's only one thing i
need to know is that you're down
material
you're down material bishop and see it
you work on a8 you're down material
yeah i mean you can you can act like
they're on the board
but in fact they don't exist now you you
could talk about oh no
what do you mean he's diamonds yeah that
bishop and ca that rook on
a they don't exist as far as this chess
position is concerned so why even bother
black
let's just develop the pieces bishop e3
rook to c1 very nicely done
and then he had to concede the move e5
anyway such an ugly move i mean thank
you very much for
all the light squares now let's put our
knight on f5
and now when you play bishop takes or
your bishop is
no longer a problem but thanks for
giving us all 32 light squares
all of them i mean that bishop on g2
just
oh this is going to be good
that bishop on g2 just knows it's going
to be a monster for
all time and what can you do you have to
be very careful for b7 you got to be
very careful with the d5 square
and that's exactly what transpired and
you see the next
move knight to c4 uh trying some
trickery
bishop g5 this move this bishop is
saying i don't need to be the hero
we know who the hero is it's that bishop
on g2
that's the hero we need to just clear
everybody out the way so this bishop can
have
the last laugh and in this position of
course trades trades now the knight on
c4 is hanging
rook d8 and then bishop takes f6 you got
to love that move the final clearance
idea
yeah uh get bishop e4 in uh
not not that i'm a fan not at all of
black's position i think his
last chance was the move queen d8 you
just got to clear the c
file and you're playing nah
i mean it's a it's a very bad position
but i think that the move rook d8 is
simply
refuted by uh nepo's next move which is
takes takes yeah before queen d8 hung
the b-pawn
and maybe the a-pawn though uh yeah well
at this point
uh i'm just thinking you're doing me a
favor
at this point i don't have to worry
about the pawns anymore if they don't
exist
no i'm sorry you i i do have a trick i
i do have a queen of three is playable
there maybe you might still play with e4
i i got some trickery i i i would dream
of this maurice i mean compared to
what's going on in the game
i mean i don't doubt sorry i don't doubt
you my friend that queen d8 does have
issues but i think rook d8 just actually
makes it loses loses the game yeah loses
the game on the spot
for this level yes yeah and let me just
refresh my board because again this is
simply a huge result
for our tournament leader after and
after bishop e4 we've seen queen a5
something similar
you got it you got to get your queen off
of this
horrible pin he's looking at checks he's
looking at
takes okay knight c3
desperation mode king f8 played after
knight c3
and you know nepo he's not gonna sit
there and calculate he's not grizz chuck
he sees that when he goes for it he
played knight d5 putting that pressure
on kirill on time as well that
i defies a sweet move to play i gotta
say i love i love knight c3
and i love knight d5 your h-pawn is
irrelevant
how many people would just say i'll take
the pawn and then make some move
no yeah yeah
and he said you know what that part's
not going anywhere anytime
soon and again there's the pawns sitting
there waiting
no no no i'm finishing you off i'm gonna
get this done knight to d5
you're you're not winning two pieces for
the rook forget about that because
there's going to be a queen c8
sighting bing bing bing sorry dude
you're gone
the knight on c4 drops and everything
else
will happen for real so knight d5
saying what's your next move you're
still making moves you're still trying
to make this last
you know how people are they don't they
don't want to resign in under 25 moves
or under 22.
you know let's let's play a little bit
longer i lost that securities
this one here after knight d5 now with
knight f6 on tap
what are you supposed to do i'm not even
sure what your next move is
i i by the way one minute 40 seconds for
carol
i think he's gonna throw in the towel or
his trainer peter svidler
is about to throw in the child i always
love these interviews where
you know you know a blushing vladimir
kramnik would come
on the the the the press conference and
he said
i wanted to resign but i didn't and then
he drew
draws the game this is one of those
games where you say
you know i want to resign i don't want
to see any more i've seen enough you've
played
this wasn't the candidates he would have
resigned like if there was an open
tournament or something like this
right right but the whole world in an
open tournament
is watching yeah in an open tournament
you could resign and
you know the quiet person next to you on
the left or the right notice you lost
like this
yeah the whole planet is staring at you
right now
right just like uh where's my corner
all the way going to towel i need i need
to
go yeah there's a commercial
that's like that it's like want to get
away yes yes
good morning cleveland all right
i just want to go i just what do i need
to do to not environment
away further it's one of those right now
he's
i mean this is bad okay i mean lots of
tempting choices i think
queen takes h7 and threatening mate is a
good start
knight hits f6 you have to calculate a
little bit of queen takes h7 you just
have to make sure of a little trick i
think
that which stakes
queen d2 yeah i don't think that this is
much of a trick right
i mean even if i get into a bishops of
opposite color
oops
[Laughter]
i was about to play check and queen g8 i
just needed to excuse
this looks hopeless for black and it's
still the best position i think i can
get
i know i know so queen takes h7
definitely gift me the pawn
is one idea the move you mentioned
maurice i gotta tell you
knight f6 just looks ugly
like devastatingly ugly i mean just
oh everything's gone wrong check i want
to go
i tap it's queenie i'm not even playing
i'm not even playing the game and i
won't cry i mean
i know i know oh
so very very very bad showing for cyril
but i got to tell you guys this is like
nepo's dream
like i mean yeah you guys are chasing me
you're all in the back uh half a point
let me take the lead by by defeating the
lowest rated player in the field
carol and by the way carol saved a tough
game yesterday
against fabi where he played outstanding
with his
wall remember let's
if we want an explanation guys kiro
has played the longest games of the
event so far
right yesterday's game for sure and then
or maybe maximus played the longest game
magazine too right
into the wee hours but remember kiro his
game against chris
he that was a long affair yes finally
defeated greg
a long affair and then this game
against fabi yeah both i mean
fatigue starts to matter when you are
not the highest rated player in the
event in fact let's just
flip it when you're the lowest rated
player in the event and people are
pressuring you on every move they're
challenging you you've got to work
super hard to try to stay in
every single game every single game you
know
they're coming for you all guns blazing
it's easy
to slip up suddenly have a collapse
right
this he knows he's prepared he's young
no question about it but he doesn't have
the experience as these big dogs at this
level
and to try to stay with them round after
round after round
remember he got the in the event as a
wild card as well so a lot to prove
you belong here be confident we
we picked you you can do it but when
you've got to face these
27 90s shark 2 800
sharks it's hard to stay in the mix
and he's finding it difficult right now
and
clearly this game is not is going to be
tossed out
is for him one of the most forgettable
he's ever played
you know i'm gonna counter with
something there maurice i agree with
a lot of the things you've said
obviously it's not easy to play against
these players
but in some ways i feel this is just a
failure of preparation i would
understand
if this happened to him in the
candidates
last year and you just don't have time
to prepare for everything he got
a spot and then you got a couple months
right and you gotta prepare right e4 d4
oh you're white like you have to prepare
so much but he had a year
to fix his repertoire any hole that he
could have
he had a year to prepare for this and
this is a
basic catalan it's a d4 less catalan
it's part of many many grand masters
repertoires
you should be able to come out of the
opening alive
yeah i i would just butcher another
point which is
exactly here this position queen takes
c4
jan has been playing this with the very
interesting ideas of b3 bishop b2
queen c2 and knight g5 i've seen a
number of games
also against shaq nemmy daroff
in other words jan you could count
on yan having this position now
10 moves later you're lost strategically
lost just bad
so i agree with you it was a fair it was
a
really bad failure of prep a6 queen c2
and i'm just saying that we get to a
position
where you're strategically gone right
here you're already
it's it's really bad so prep you're
right
prep bad prep and sometimes you get
caught and this is kind of my point
right sometimes you get caught in the
opening
in open tournaments or even in some
round robins where
you just haven't looked at that
variation you forgot about it what to do
but this is the candidates guys like
it's a different tournament you're
supposed to be so
completely prepared against anything
they can throw at you and if yasser
you're mentioning that
nepo plays this exactly he does it's
terrible
yeah 22 moves by the way he could have
resigned on any move
before this nice c3 move 21 knight c3 i
know you could have said maybe a little
bit even earlier
but move 21 knight c3 nobody would have
faulted him
for resigning in this position right
here i mean it's just
that bad and then when knight d5
happened
for sure you could resign like just stop
b5 is ridiculous to let your king get
shattered like this knight f6 and
queen h7 or queen f6 and you just this
is just
miserable i think the only reason you
don't resign here is that white has so
many choices
you were saying uh lavon lavon's
expression
just just give me a very very very clear
and narrow path to victory i'm happy
don't give me too many different options
and that's the problem white does have
some good options
but once he settles on one i think it
hits its mark whether it be knight f6 or
queen h7
uh it's just it's just terrible let's
jump back to the game between
uh the world's number two and three
players
fabi uh because this even though fabi
is down a pawn at the moment these
double pawns in the center of the board
to my way of thinking are bad
they're just bad and i like white's
compensation
when we left it we just left it after
knight c6 somehow i thought
that fabi might play a little bit slower
a move like
h3 he just immediately went 94.
i think this is a big strategical threat
i don't think you
want to see that knight landing on d6
and he has to get on e4 for that yeah i
was about i was about to say
i i wouldn't want that knight hanging
over me too long
and he captured on e4 all right
so this is our situation what's our
assessment
it's a tough one to evaluate it's not so
much
about the extra pawn or not the extra
pawn because honestly they're so weak
right but on the other hand do these
pawns give me enough central squares
that i can play with them for example
can i get something to d5 where it'll be
very well anchored can i get something
to d4 world
it will be very well anchored something
like rook d8
i think exploit that my pawn on e6 is
covering some crucial squares in the
center
and i can maybe post up my rook on d5
there you go
maybe start pressuring that pawn on c5 i
think that both sides have chances
obviously white has compensation
the question will be is it enough for an
advantage
and that's a tough one to ask he's going
to have to pressure the e file he's
going to have to pressure the king's
side
i think that he's going to be heavily
eyeing moves like h4 knight g5
uh to start really asking questions on
both sides of the board
interesting you know yeah i'm glad you
pointed out the move h4 because i was
wondering
what white was playing for other than
the pawn on e5 because you can imagine
the pawn on e5
dropping off the board but and even upon
an e6 you'll say i got a pawn on e5 then
i get the pawn on e6
black would gladly trade off those two
pawns for your one pawn
on c5 and say okay we've liquidated
everybody
what advantage do you have you could see
some queen rook ending where nobody's
winning
so if all you're doing is going after
the pawns to say let me pressure them
they're weak i win them i could then go
on to win the game
that's going to be technically very
difficult to pull off
but a move like h4 says you know what
forget about those pawns they suck
anyway
let me see if i can do something else to
weaken your position make it
a little bit softer this move h4 is a
very dynamic idea looking for
more in the position than just trying to
win back some pawn
is it good it does concede the d4 square
for the black knight
and the c5 pawn then looks like it's
going to drop
really quickly with black's activity
coming super fast
behind that as well so watch out
this this position you can tell you know
fabi's not just looking for
a little bit he needs more than just
winning back pawns
but is it so easy to win the pawn on c5
i know what you're saying maurice i i
win the pawn on e5 i win the pawn on e6
you get the c5 pawn we get into a rook
and upon end game
draw agreed we're we're friends after
all but
is it so easy for black to win this pawn
on c5 because it's like okay if we just
do it in this fashion
right there's a pin on the line
and suddenly it's not an ending it's
still
you know white for choice i would say
uh so it might not just be that easy
to win back the pawn on c5 well rook v8
is on the board so we're going to see
this line probably rook
d a rookie one rook d5 let's go down
that line knight takes e5
is there another move here other than
taking on e5
immediately exactly there is there
another move there's a knight
d4 possibility
which certainly sharpens things up
knight d4 and where do you put the queen
uh well let me just
kind of uh snuggle up as they say
i want to take and again i i'm i'm
um yeah this
smells very fishy potential but not yet
and then that afternoon will work as
long as the queen is defended
precisely you get your discovered check
but you're pretty embarrassed that the
queen is defended
so yeah a knight d4 queen c4
still feels like like white's for choice
in that case i don't know
maybe rook d5 is just not very good
we don't have rook e1 or rook d5 on the
board
yet the alternative may be knight d4
immediate
immediately maybe something like
this is a makes more sense there's d3
also
in the position i'm worried about
something like queen c4
okay yes uh again uh
i can imagine threats of double
checkmate
do you do get your attention it's like
oh wait what
oh boy but on the other hand after king
h8 i don't know if i'm actually
threatening anything
it's it's beautiful yeah but it looks
like a back ring
made until you see this oh man party
pooper
okay so it's
intriguing position for sure i'm
i'm waiting for rook e1 and we'll see
how it unfolds
once again that combination by the way
what's interesting yes after uh
just play out just same combination and
i saw another move there
takes takes queen c4 moves takes on c5
it takes and queen takes a
queen takes a6 queen takes d4
queen takes a6 right and you can do
either one but we get back to the point
that you might reach one of these end
games
this is the whole play we were making
earlier and is it really not good right
you could win all those pawns but
so what what so what yeah yeah i can
imagine that
queen takes d4 with uh with
uh so many majors on the board black's
king is a little bit more vulnerable
than white's king
but there we're talking you know
technic yeah it's small it's a small
advantage but
yeah will you actually win it i was like
eight six in that position
right to lift the back rank mate maybe
even even queen e6 i think was okay
queen before queen e6 oh that's cute
every time i think i'm going to get you
from behind
you got your own problems yeah i got my
own uh
issues yes yeah no i it's going to
liquidate and that's the problem if
you're not careful
this is why fabi is spending some time
thinking right here because he realizes
if he just goes gung-ho for the pawns on
e5 and e6 he knows just as well as we do
this might liquidate easily into nothing
and
why why are you playing like this and
that's why i really liked your idea
alejandro if it's legit of playing for
something
else in the position h4 also lifts the
back rank issues for white
so there are no tactics in the wild
tactics in the long run
but then again i think you need to play
rook e1 for is that everything
you played it was rookie one he hasn't
played but i think rookie one
seems important because if you don't
have this pressure on e6
94 just is really strong right you're
undoubling your pawns you're creating a
pass pawn d3 will be a threat
but is this real so let's take a look
this is very critical knight takes d4
pawn takes d4
rook takes e6 yeah and it's the truth of
it's the truth of knights knights are
those jester pieces on the board that
keep the imbalance
when you start getting to pure linearity
once the knights are off the board
then it's all about diagonals and ranks
and files
and if they don't give you anything it's
just like it's just dead you just
nothing for you to do
and we see the tactics here we're trying
all these linear tactics
that don't end up going anywhere there's
no back rank action and
anything like that oh that moves with
you
oh now that's a linear tactic that you
got a bad question too
some back rank action maybe bishop a3 is
meant by
queen takes c8 winning
uh at least an exchange but no no that's
game over
that's got to be right yeah bishop f8 is
the only move there
we should point out bishop f8 was the
only move and then takes on c8 and
defend but
you're you're not going to fight the
russians
here here bishop f8 rook takes and king
g8
and it looks like you're going to get
gobbled uh
you're just down the exchange which
doesn't matter down a real exchange
with with threats coming so
so that's a nice idea even if you can
get ideas
some something to go on well go on
if you have rookie five that's huge for
the game
queen c for king h8 and rookie five what
does he do
um bishop he does that bishop f8
now to deal with the back rank early
because if i
take and i take and rookie 8 i have rook
bb8
no no actually no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no no i
can take and it's mate it's not chuck
it's not checking yeah yeah
it's still an issue and uh yeah the
background's an issue
whoops yep hoisted on my own pitard
there
oh dear okay so bishop f8
is actually that's a great move wow
but maybe oh because rook on e5 is
hanging so i don't have queen f7
rookie rook takes e5 oh boy oh boy
so king h8 i don't have any moves
here if i just get out of the back rank
mate with h3 maybe d3
no i can take it really asking for it
yeah yeah i could even take maybe
maybe just play like h6 or remove
yourself
it's an ugly move though i i understand
the hesitation to
write rook h6 right yeah that kind of
thing
bishop c1 hx okay double edged
it's double-edged hold on hold on let's
stay in this position here because we
need a
we need a real move before h3
here what is black's threat black
doesn't threaten bishop takes
a3 i think bishop f8 might be
a threat where black gets to trade
everything off and say i'm fine
yes crazy that black's okay here i mean
i'm still trying to fight
exactly exactly it does feel that
thanks to the domination of the open
file
the slightly more vulnerable black king
there should be a knockout but well i
mean
either there's a knockout or there isn't
right i mean the back rank your back
rank is weak
and it's just one file if you can just
trade it down then everything disappears
so bishop a3 is the threat at the moment
very concrete
uh idea not i shouldn't say it's at the
moment that tension of the
bishop a3 once black solves the
background problem
then there's nothing there's nothing
along the open lines that i think
white would be worried about the
question maybe the queen is on a bad
square
i can't believe that though well c4
this is all very interesting but after
rook 8e1
dingleran instantly replied with the
move bishop f6
keeping some tension on the board saying
hey knight d4 might be strong
but guess what i also can play for a win
why do i need to release the tension let
me
keep a hold of this pawn on e5 let me
keep it alive
i'll maneuver around it i'll put my rook
on d5 and slowly
improve there is no reason for me to
simplify the position right now and we
got a game in our hands
well wow nice this is this is what fabi
is glad to see i think if this i think
so too
i mean yes keep the game going because
now the ideas of h4 and knight g5 start
to maybe creep in but also even
dare i push g4 at some point that
why not i wouldn't start with it but i
would in a bullet game you play h4
and then you think and if g4 presents
itself then you go for it right like
something
like h4h6 you can start considering g4
immediately
i don't see why not well knight d4 is
coming though so we've got to be ready
for that
knight d4 with d3 at the end
one of the things that i was thinking is
that my my queen
might just not be on an ideal square
uh although again c4 is fine right
yeah and you still have queen takes d3
here
it's useful at the same time it's
extremely important
very very very important very useful
and thanks to the move h4 as well
strangely enough i was at the
point where instead of the move h4 i was
again you know really
uh angling for this move i was thinking
that
in such a case of queen c4 i'm just
sidestepping knight d4 because i got the
move knight e5
as a rejoinder and i was expecting that
after
rook d5 then i like what you guys are
discussing
h4 and g4
i have a result in the most predictable
result
nepomniacci has defeated kirill
alex senko what a result for the
standings
because that means that after today
nepomniacci will be the leader
of the candidates it doesn't matter
what happens in the other games they
can't catch him the question will only
be
how big of a lead is it what a huge
result for nepal
not breaking a sweat and we know how
important that is in this kind of
tournaments where
fatigue becomes an issue he didn't
have to try today guys he played some
normal moves
and he just destroyed his opponent
it was it was a one-sided affair
terribly one-sided at this high level
uh everybody loses games everybody if
you play chess you're going to lose some
games
but the kind of games you want to lose
is where you feel you've been in
in in a scrap your your opponent had
played brilliantly
and uh you worked really hard well look
at the time
look at the clocks and you see nepo had
it was all one one sided that's back to
that fine form that he showed in the
first half of the tournament
when he won three out of six games i
tell you this guy you don't want him to
start winning games he could rack up
a couple of wins very easily and puts
the pressure on the rest of the players
in the event
big game for him absolutely
amazing and what a round he will have
tomorrow
because remember he plays fabiano carona
we have a rest day tomorrow
oh tough on fabi tough on fabi indeed
but
uh yes that's this result guys it
it can't be overstated i mean he's his
odds of winning the tournament
first of all anyone who's not in the top
four the top four
have been effectively eliminated after
this win just
anyone not in the top four just go right
you're not catching this number from
where you are right now that just
we we don't believe in fairy tales the
other three
also know boy you can't lose
you can't lose another game not with his
number you just can't
the the next three they're they're
currently a point and a half
out none of these three can afford to
lose a game
like that's that's just disastrous and
then on top of that they've got to
somehow try to keep
pace maxima and fabi actually
do play yan anish has already played him
so anish can't touch him at all and he's
going to say well maybe i you know
i got him in round 12. i can i can get a
shot at him
no that's done you already drew your
game against him
so fabi and maxime maxine may be with
more doesn't doesn't maximize him with
black also
in the last because maxime played
against
french in the last round so you should
be black against uh
yeah against jan in the last that means
so that means maxine gets him in the
last round with
exactly bobby gets him in the next round
with black
so he's two pursuers two people who can
actually affect his score they will have
black against him
guys he couldn't have written a better
script for himself winning today
he's an amazing situation
game for him to play and win could be
the whole tournament this victory
could be well yeah a lot of the things
he will avoid is a zagreb
i remember yeah he's yeah it's a well oh
there's no magnus there's no magnus
zagreb had magnus to say
excuse me magnus couldn't pull the
can pull the brakes on anybody's streak
there's no magnus here
well that's what we're trying to find
out right this people are trying to be
the world champion they need to have
that steel that magnus carlsen brings to
the games
he they need to say hey i can do that
too because jan is running away with it
right now right and they will have black
could we add let's remind every they
will have black both of them
maxime and uh and fabio
both have black against him right
that's big i just uh brought up the game
between wang hao and alex and
der grishoek while it might not be a big
match as far as our standings are
concerned the time clock situation
you're always attracted when you're in a
playing hall
and you're making moves and stand up
from from the board i tell you
it's like a magnet you always are
attracted to the game where somebody's
in time
trouble and you can see that they're in
trouble because their legs go
like this and if they're feverishly
looking around the board
we just saw a very nice move i wanted to
point out this queen trap because
i just find it very attractive uh wang
i don't know if he needed to play the
move knight b3 i was expecting bishop g2
myself
he played knight b3 and inviting
uh this is not uh the poison pawn
variation of the naidorf where you get
to take away the b2 pawn
because after whoops knight
c1 the bishops cover all the retreat
squares
and the queen is captured hence we saw
the move knight e4
and when you played the move knight b3
i'm sure wang how
expected the move knight e4 what do you
think he intended as
the follow-up gentleman well there's two
choices only right queen d3 or
bishop takes b6 bishop takes knight
takes d2
the end game how do we feel about that
just taking on d2 saying you have a
little bit of a crippled pawn structure
but
those two bishops they are a little bit
scary
and if you get in the movie e5 maybe he
has something like take stakes
bishop well i don't know i mean
i'm still uh as a french defense player
i want to play
e5 i don't know if i like this ending as
much but
i'm not really a big fan of moving my
queen either
it's strange would you have played
knight b3 wouldn't you both have just
said bishop g2 stopping e5
um let black solve
the problems of the pin you can't
uh jump right away because now i've got
a very nasty discovered attack so
i don't know if i like this move knight
b3
this is so normal unless i'm missing
something
bishop g2 queen b2 oh that's
embarrassing
ah thank you for clearing the comments i
didn't understand
what that means this a beautiful
uh fork thank you alejandro
well somebody's awake that's good
i'm on my second coffee nice
nice one okay that's what
okay that really does make a lot more
sense suddenly
yeah so there was an actual threat in
the position with queen b2 he has to get
rid of it
knight b3 but yeah then then you start
thinking about moves like knight b3
right
yes exactly but you have to see queen b2
as an actual threat too
all right knight b3 knight e4 we're back
on track
okay let's try a different approach
queen d3
just saying okay i am attacking your
queen i want to play bishop g2 and i
want to take this knight
off the board are we playing backwards
what else do you have no but you can
it's such a strange position because
this queen
wants a good square i really want to put
it in a better square
what's your ideal square for black
that's the thing right yeah
i'm not sure what the best way is e7 a
great square i mean should you go queen
c7 to e7
um let's put it on d8
it does have a purpose immediately
because i maybe
can get away with e5 here
give me this pawn and give me this pawn
maybe i can't get away with e5 yeah i
don't know
it's uh it the the the center
black center is a little shaky let's
just put it like that i
it's not most solid
but if you're not playing for e5 i'm not
really too sure
maybe it's time to just say okay okay
okay
you you got the best of me i have to go
back
no it was a french player that's too sad
wait a minute as a french player we all
know the knights belong on
f5 not e4 e4 is far too aggressive
too aggressive for our french player
yeah f5
f5 and c4 you're squares you're a french
defense player
which which side i'm gonna say either
side but
you know me i'm from brooklyn we got to
castle queensland
queenside it's not so crazy because your
vulnerable center might get under attack
very easily you long castle rook heichi
one knight d4
again the thing about the french right
if you don't get e5 in you're basically
playing down a piece
this guy the bane of the french i'm
counting on the fact that i'm pressuring
d5 and
you're running out of moves plus plus i
might play
i'm don't don't think i'm not going to
play g4
at some point and really try to hurt
your feelings
yeah somehow i feel that blacks down too
many tempe and development here
fair fair i i don't disagree i
so the more i'm looking at it i'm
not going to go into the ending with
bishop b6 but i am going to go into the
middle game with queen d3 and bishop g2
looks favorable once again let's just
let me see if there's
sorry i just wanted to say see the
position for one second
no that's just too crazy yeah you gonna
play night
night before but no i can't
like you punish me if punishing me for
doing something that i don't see
what i've done uh that is so
that uh terribly wrong
yeah no well this at least this is
unnecessary
i think it's unnecessary i think you
should just move the knight back to d2
but
i mean this also doesn't look amazing i
have to admit
for black why couldn't i play bishop d2
in the previous position
like when you did this thing no not this
one
not this one no no i don't want this one
i mean
instantly yes what am i gonna be
suffering from no i don't know if
they're suffering i
i mean it's a peace sacrifice for
nebulous compensation
what can i say i just don't like the
position i was trying to make something
work
sometimes in this french defense you
have to make use of the fact that the
bishop's not on g2 and then
one check a lonely check the king on e1
might not have a good
resource right but in this one
it looks fine that's i'm wondering
what's taking him so long to play queen
d3 because he's spending an
awful lot of time in this position is
the most natural looking move
and i think he's probably looking at
knight before or spent some time at
least
to look at knight b4 because he's got to
feel like
dude your position looks terrible and
right if i just make these next two
moves
you you could be just gone
and uh maybe he's calculating this queen
b6
although what happens after knight d4
looks like a piece i mean he's very
something he has to be worried about
an idea and
something like this now this would have
this would be a dream
at least you you feel like you're in
there kicking
like some kind of chance yeah
practical chess like my students like to
say practical so maybe
so what is so then then he has to
calculate the alternative if if this
bishop d2 queen b6 is that annoying
on you can't really find an easy
i was looking for an easy consolidating
move does queen e3 do it
maybe maybe queen e3 i mean i'm always
ready to give the b-pawn up i'll take
the piece over the two pawns for sure of
course
no no no i feel i feel naive force a
little bit
too much fantasy but that's like before
so then probably in trouble what is he
thinking about then
what does he think about if he doesn't
play queen d3 right now queen d3 bishop
g2
is just what the doctor ordered right
easy choice so what is wang hao spending
so much clock time
i don't know how much time but we've
been able to discuss this we've been
here for a while
so much clock time looking at this
position yeah especially because the end
game seems so
not promising right i don't know maybe
it is
uh promising after all it is a really
ugly structure
even if you get in the move e5 it's not
like that
souls yeah but the king on d2 is so
weak i know it looks weird right
leading with your chin and uh by the way
guys
yes by the way we haven't looked at this
game in a while this game between
mvl and anish geary and i wanted to get
to that
development there the blockade was
finally lifted but because
anish forced it to be lifted he decided
to not go for any of the aggressive
ideas we had mentioned with g5 and f5
all that good stuff with the king on h8
he said let me play
completely differently and after b5
bishop to b3
he did the old switcherooni was that
knight on a6 once
upon a time yes yeah yeah right in the
opening it was
he decided to put it back to a6 ignore
the d5 pawn and give white
this move queen e2 and then knight c5
uh was played i think it was the next
move yes and give me the b
pawn why not
some compensation is the argument on the
b line
after rook why did nothing with the
queen
i think he wanted to to develop his rook
but you're right my first uh my first
instinct was queen
takes b b3 but okay
look at this so opposite color opposite
color
bishop middle game extra pawn for white
practical chances did you call them
they particularly call it the practical
aspect of chess
this is when they make a move that makes
no sense but they play
quickly okay uh even weak news played
quickly can be impressive
um i don't know guys but i would not
want to embrace this position but that
this is their lifetime results
anish geary with a lot of draws never
have i seen this
shock not fair look at that three to
three two
big ganks big dog gangsters like this
play draw numbers should be very high
i'm sure there are other
results other matchups that feature many
many classical chess draws
as well so i know everybody wants to be
beating
bashing on a niche for drawing so much
but
if it's clear at this level this is
usually the result
uh the result is often a comment i think
i think i read somewhere that
anisha's draws are just more noticeable
because sometimes they're
so far in a row but they're not actually
in a higher percentage
than than the other players
he draws more or less the same as
anybody else and he wins
about as much as anybody else at the top
level so we like to joke but yeah
fairness to anishi
he does play some amazing chess and a
lot of fighting chess you have to see
that he actually made a conscious effort
in his repertoire
to make more uh the game sharper
exactly to sharpen it up again uh he
became
a very strong solid grand master
uh keeping his russian defense petrov
defends to one
e4 intact and he beat players like
hikaru nakamura for example
on the black side of those petrov's and
then you saw this very conscious
decision as he was maturing as he got
into his twenties
that you know what he's gonna mix up mix
it up and he started
playing different types of sicilians
and well playing them very well this
position however i'm sure
is not one that he wanted to get this
particular position
with white having you know a runaway
criminal
uh all the way on d6 already and uh
bishops of opposite color
this strikes me as dangerous for for
black how serious is it i'm not sure
let's take a look
let's get back let's get back to a
position
we talked about we wanted to see happen
it's happened the fobby game
and the board is lighting up
oh my wow but we saw
i was thinking of moving the queen
to get out of a potential knight d4 idea
he moved his rook
because he said ah i'm not going
queen side i do believe
i'm going king side go ahead drop your
knight in on d4
and allow me to play queen g6 i've got
big
aspirations and look at it g4 bigger
than
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah top players draw a lot i don't
think this one's ending in a draw
i feel like there's going to be blood
spilled by somebody
in this game geforce move number 26
14 moose to go and
and only 17 minutes on the clock
left for fabi in this electrifying
position
wow number two in the world number two
playing number three
and we get to be treated to this game
guys
i tell you the move bishop f6 the one
that uh
you know right here we had
seriously we had focused all of our
energies on the move rook d5
instantly came the move bishop f6 we
were already kind of moving into that
direction
h4 knight g5 and not not going for
something really forcing
concrete captures at the pawn on e5 and
this move bishop f6
does provoke uh fabi
into directly into this line of play i
don't think dear dingler in
uh is happy about this move i think that
this is
really bad news for black actually
testing but look i'm sorry go ahead yeah
please
i'm i'm actually wondering what the real
thread is so let's say i kind of
pass i don't know how yeah it's okay
i'll make a passing move and you're
right i just wanted to understand like
where exactly white's attacking crash
through like what are the threats how do
i defend against them right
g5 all right i'll take
having said a having said a i will say b
okay i will pay you uh an
unexpected visit so uh i'm thinking
queen and and pawn this looks very
annoying i think i need to cover
the g6 square somehow queen e8
instead of an a5 move makes sense yeah
queen e8 protecting the square g g5
okay i also think that g5 will be more
uncomfortable because i can get queen
h5 in as black but the h file opens
though so
after this you can play king to g2
maybe not even russian maybe you start
with king g2
you could also start with king g2 oh
sorry
right here we're saying yeah keep the
tension for now
g2 with the idea of playing g5 you do
get the open h
line coming so no need to rush chessy
although
i don't don't oh knight d4 knight d4
now doesn't really slow you down 94
takes maybe you can consider taking with
a rook
rook i think king g2
strikes me as like you know an extra
goodness
i mean i'd like i'd like to you know
like pound the table you know
uh i i always like this about larry
christensen
the guy he he had a very big club
you know like he would be swinging it
he'd knock himself out
a few times but when it landed on you
you were getting up
and here i think it's time to swing the
big club i mean
it feels yeah okay
let's just go let's just go
and now the minus we should we should
know the minuses that black
uh obviously created within his own
position
the move h6 allowed for g5 to be a move
to to hook onto this h6 pawn and the
move
also weak in the g6 square right right
that's that but white has played
g4 g5 creating his own weaknesses his
king is further exposed exposed
and by pushing the bishop to c to e7
c5 now becomes a straight tempo that he
can exploit so
both sides are playing specific chess
like you you better play super
accurately from this moment
so now you want to play rook h3
and knock them bishop g5 your 95 is weak
in that square
there's there's a lot to calculate here
well the queen could get to age five
like you could do something like this
you mean no
not in this position you would take i
i'm guessing
and get your queen to h5 where you could
potentially harass
my king that is certainly one
why couldn't and why couldn't i do it on
the last why couldn't i even done it
without taking i'm sorry
without continuing your line we're
analyzing your line it takes takes
midnight uh sometimes i get lost uh
maurice you should just
uh give me the move uh no i want it yeah
i want to
right here just keep going you're lying
knight takes knight takes on e5 takes
and why can't i play queen h5 after rook
takes
i thought e7 was hanging but maybe
it's not it's not it's not because i got
queen g5
exactly there's a nice geometry there
let me just show
uh folks in the audience well
that picks up the exchange so no
but rook takes pawn takes
um is it time to
well but the queen g4 move creeps back
in yeah we're not playing
i'm not playing this for a win no
so that's the problem you you black
created weaknesses
but white created weaknesses in order to
exploit black's weaknesses
that's just that's just at the highest
you got to get squares to get squares
you got to give them jesus
and now c5 is hanging that's the point
you push
black back but now you got to deal with
c5 is it
good or not i don't know but that's
maybe maybe it's true playing king
g2 to wait just a second it's something
again again about my queen i'd like my
queen
to be more how do you say
more dare to be i mean i i want it to be
in in the thick of things the action
and i somehow the c2 square whether it's
whether it's because i i'm defending c5
and i don't want to be in that
situation i want to get in g4
g5 g6 and my queen but here knight d4 no
knight d4 okay trying to take advantage
of
live with yeah off the g you can't take
this knight
i think because we could but
no no rook takes rotates for sure
the problem is for issues yeah g4 is
having an h4 is hanging so i didn't see
uh
so let's look at king g2 because i i
personally
i'm attracted to that more than queen e4
maybe that's difference of styles right
i think it's more direct it's a move
that i really want to play and i think
in my personal opinion that the queen i
don't know where it wants to go
i don't know if he wants to go to e4 i
don't know if he wants to go to c4
it has this dual purpose on c2 right now
it pushes the c
pawn it eyes the king side and unless
there's like knight d4 actually bothers
me
then i'd rather leave it there so let's
analyze right 94
might be critical queen eight by the way
played
invitingly randomly a logical move
because it's what we've been looking at
uh i kind of have to do i have to take
this
the necessity of protecting g6
was really getting uh you know tellingly
obvious
uh yeah that was another thing about the
move knight d4 if my queen
was not sitting on c2 it it would give
me an
option of knight e5 but 94 it's very
forcing and if you
do capture yeah here i actually i had an
idea from afar but i didn't know if it
worked
c6 c7 a pardon me c
i wish it was 5 6 yeah yeah yeah are you
going to get c7 i mean
you're not far you're just busy yeah not
letting your
day i think i have to play rook g3
because i don't want to give up all my
pawns
it makes a ton of sense to keep
exchanging pieces if you can because
yeah because i want to push this guy
that's my star yeah
star runner yeah yeah here
my extra pawns yeah no i like the spawn
on c7
and just as i liked mvl's passer on d6
i like this pawn also uh in this exact
position after c6
maybe i i don't have to uh
jump hold the opportunity the pawn the
pawn on c7 looks attractive
but you were down material you were down
two pawns now to start so i want to take
that pawn on g4
i want to see that end game and i want
to see what white plans to do
to potentially uh lift this blockade so
why can't you
do exactly what we said and i just want
to understand i'm sure a lot of
viewers would like to understand as well
you're down two pawns you're not going
to mate and you can't let the blockade
so how are you playing because queen the
queen is going to attack this pawn
the bishop will show up at some point
like queen b5
your king is exposed i'm not sure this
bishop will show up at some point
well i'm going to put a bishop on d6
okay so then i'm just going to hold
on queen b5
rook d1 let's say i don't want to allow
that queen maybe king h2 is a good move
here just keeping just to get
yeah what i'd like to do
uh alejandro is tie him up with rook v8
you know now that you put the bishop on
d6 you
you've protected the b8 square just
avoid that queen d5
check so now
queen b6
getting sharp sorry i i feel like
this is kind of a two result game i
can't see black
being happy with such a position me
either i don't like
and i'm a pawn grubber and i don't like
being in these
situations where you know like i
don't have enough counter play um
yeah if we could just go back for uh
because
excuse me uh king
g2 by the g2 is on the board
so 94 besides
94 because that's
i don't know 94 is committal
yeah besides knight d4 could we go back
to just uh
one of the great defensive techniques um
that i learned over the ages is when
you're facing a
pawn storm like black is facing a pawn
storm
is move your pieces out of the way
before the pawns advance with tempo
and let me just try this move bishop e7
uh
getting out of the way of g
for g5
yeah 95 it does does 95 work
well i do get to trade some stuff right
that's
kind of right that that that's the good
news i get to trade some stuff
yeah i was kind of hoping knight g6
worked but i forgot e3's hanging
so yeah probably that's not enough hold
on what about knight c6 here
bishop c5 knight bishop c5 uh
that was one of the reasons why maybe i
wasn't so happy about my king okay and
now i'm showing
when i move the king where would you
like to move the king
or i can't play f3 that's a little crazy
um and it's funny that this kind of
positions you want to
safeguard your king it actually reminds
me of dingleran's uh king yesterday
where there was a queen on c6 and a king
on g2 but it didn't matter what you
played the king
couldn't get out of that diagonally
right right it was really annoying for
him
by the way i'm being told that uh sasha
not surprisingly is down to a minute
on his clock let's just go back to this
yeah
he did play queen d3 did uh wang hao
and wang hao is sensing it i mean
after after bad outing yesterday
he realizes he's got
opportunity today because of the clock
and look at the position
the position looks like uh a nice
even right side of the front whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa
wait this shot f5 but i love
a lot of pieces are suddenly hanging
afterwards
and you cannot you should not think on
f6
why not because
what's the intended follow up is
d5 right yeah i take on d5 and i take on
c4 and
kind of by magic i'm defending my knight
on e2 so that's three pieces
no we always love the three pieces
against the queen
uh when we have a safe king of course
yeah i was about to say it very much
depends
on the game and the king position this
one it looks also like the pieces cannot
be disturbed
queen e4 looks like a move you'd like to
play
but knight to d4 right something can
land on d4 and you'd
you'd love to put your bishop over on h3
in this position so maybe that's let's
let's do that instead
let's bring the knight back to b3 and in
this position after bishop takes the
weakness is
the bishop left that diagonal let's play
bishop f5 well hold on hold on we're
going a little
fast let's make sure we're not
blundering anything because we're not
using an engine or anything like that
and we went through this very quickly d
f takes bishop f5
so i take on f6 you have to take back
right yeah maybe the move rook f5
works you're letting this pawn live
no but even even knight bd4 is a double
attack right
knight oh pardon me i just hit the wrong
key there i apologize for that
takes on c2 takes on e7 rook f5
oh my but you said knight
well it's the bishop to launch right now
this is too much
no d5 is hanging and on the board guys
on the board we have it
uh it is an exciting line i love it
tactics
because you have bishop e6 at the end
exactly like if you take on f5
to show the audience bishop takes f5
bishop takes up five
uh bishop takes d5 you still have to
move bishop e6 and that holds on to the
knight on c4 so
white ends up with a rook and a piece
for the pawn for the queen which is
quite frankly not enough
no so what is the idea after rook five
he plays the move actually he played
them with rook fe-8
instead of rook f5 whoa
but this is f e8 he's giving up the d5
pawn with check
but that's the only thing he's giving up
yeah because c4 still defended right
before he's defended
so this is a huge turn of events what
are you proving if you're
white here that your e7 pawn is that
strong
i don't buy it like what are you doing
um
and two pieces that is a bishop and a
knight dark square bishop
and a knight for this queen that you
just
decided to sacrifice and if i go to
bishop's c5
five looks almost forced but
taking on b3 no i mean i could play rook
fade
immediately but i was saving that
for i well i'm like
you know i'm winding up some
uh amazing pun what about 93 here guys
what do you think
no i i i don't i don't believe i don't
believe in this one
no i don't either yeah right
yeah okay so let's let's do it again
so by the way uh
we don't necessarily have to take right
away on d5 we
but why it's not right like what's the
decision well well
the the the reality is i
don't want my bishop on d5 i really want
my knight on d5 my knight on e2
is a bad piece oh well bad piece
relatively speaking
it's not in the thick of things if i put
my knight on d5 however
now maybe knight b6 here
knight to b6 because this knight is
always a tactical track
uh target right yep yes on c4 whenever i
get to play bishop takes d5
as you just said the knight on uh just
to point out
what we mean by a tactical target let's
show it
takes fork the queen and rook and there
it goes the tactical target so that was
why alejandro
says okay i see your knight wants to
land on d5 let me
let me uh protect the the pawn on
on d5 and get my knight away from
vulnerable square i think wang hao
overlooked her k8
it's an easy move to miss even though
it's so logical once you put it on the
board
i didn't even consider it going into the
line you see it
and you go oh yeah
[Laughter]
what about that one that makes sense to
me
uh i'm still getting i'm still
digesting the position the problem is i
can't play a move like bishop c5
when this amazing league has badly
placed bishop on c2 suddenly
could i say first before before we even
go any further
go back a couple of moves before the
queen's side
the bishop lands on f5 right and you see
this combination takes takes you can hit
d5
d5 you can take on c4 you see all these
beautiful tactics
but remember we had started by saying
white's better right black is
black is trying to get into into some
position but we like white
and so when you when you get to
this position and you see takes on f6
you're saying i'm
not just better anymore i'm winning i'm
winning
i exactly what he said i'm not and that
i'm not playing positionally move my
queen somewhere
you know no i'm winning now
so when he takes on f6 the and the
bishop takes and he takes on e7 and he's
seeing
all the hits with with uh bishop takes
after queen takes e7 bishop d5 bishop
c4 he's thinking yum yum even though
that position
is controversial as well right
which is which is to me means it's a
little irresponsible of him to go into
this line because even that position
with the three pieces is you know some
controversy but still
he sees this and he says i think that's
good then the guy plays rookie eight and
you go
um what
but he might be considering certain
alternatives once he's in this position
i think
he had an original idea if he saw rook
field he had an original idea and he
knows
that here maybe he should play his
original idea i don't know if
the original was knight f4 or bishop hd5
but that he has alternatives i don't
think it's a bad point
to take some time even if you already
had a plan um
to to go into this the question is is it
going to be
enough uh the other on the other
counterpoint did white really have that
big of an advantage because black was
kind of getting out of it right with the
e5 and you have to tactically punish
a move like this otherwise black's
pieces are suddenly prancing around you
can take on e5 next move
rook is going to come to d8 at best you
have a slight edge at worst this bishop
on e4 is going to be really annoying
because your light squares are really
weak
uh so i don't think it was clear cut
that there was something better he might
have felt
this is practical well the alternative
to the queen sacrifice might have been a
move like bishop takes d5 check right
just taking advantage of the fact that
we do
um have a queen e6 check we're not
blundering an exchange to knight e3 so
bishop takes f5 [ __ ] pardon me bishop
takes d5 check
was maybe the alternative of the queen
sacrifice
but i agree with what you're saying
alejandro if i go queen d1
and bishop maybe the advantage isn't as
great as we originally thought whereas
the alternative to the the the
queen sacrifice which is the game
position was bishop takes d5 now the
question is
do we have to take a commercial that's
the question
the urgency of the original of this
commercial
right sounds like a yes guys we will be
right
back just a couple of minutes time
pressure is looming
so we will be here soon with around 10
of the candidates
[Music]
if you have kids you already know st
louis has a ton
of fun stuff for families to do like the
magic house
or the science center and if you really
want to be a
stellar parent come see all the new
stuff there is to discover
at st louis union station with a new
mirror maze
light shows and the 20 story high
st louis wheel it's enough to make any
parent
feel like a star st lou is
always exploring you hear
it
it's the sound of hope
[Music]
and health
and strength
it's the sound of compassion of
open doors where people and machines are
in tune
and miracles occur
[Music]
it's the sound of personalized
healthcare
and active communities
it sounds like life and it's what you
hear
when you really listen listening to you
caring for you we are ascension
be surprised be intrigued be
delighted the world chess hall of fame
in st
louis is nothing you'd expect and
everything you love
three galleries highlight the history
culture and creativity behind the game
explore chess in ways you
never imagined it's a one-of-a-kind
cultural institution
where rare artifacts and world-class art
play together
the world chess hall of fame mind art
experience
founded in 1839 the university of
missouri
is steeped in tradition the recently
founded mizzou chess program
is a partnership between the university
of missouri and the st
louis chess club collegiate jess has
been experiencing a meteoric
rise at the national level through its
tradition of excellence
mizzou has always strived for the best
mizzou chess is working towards raising
the bar
by bringing our institutions ethos of
respect
responsibility discovery and excellence
to the chess board
[Music]
professional golf returns to saint louis
in 2021
the ascension charity classic presented
by emerson
stars like phil mickelson ernie else jim
furyk and more compete at norwood hills
country club
september 6 through the 12th tickets
clubhouse passes hospitality suites and
proam foursomes are on sale now
all proceeds go to north st louis county
charities visit
ascensioncharityclassic.com
or call 314-938-2828 pga tour golf is
back in the loo
the ascension charity classic
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we are back in round 10 of the
candidates tournament and we already had
a massive result as janet pomnyacci was
able to defeat his compatriot kiril
alexenko and with the round still
running
he has a one and a half point lead over
the rest of the field
yasser how about you take us around the
horn real quick let's take a look there
at the standings first
yana pony actually six and a half points
out of ten
mvl fabiano caron all of them with five
out of nine
trying to come closer to
the leader can they do it let's get us
started on some of those positions
where do we start we gotta take a look
at a lot of these games because
a lot has happened let's start with this
one fabio karan against dingley ren
what is going on how did we reach this
end game and
whoa what is going on indeed okay
i mean uh sorry i wanted to get to the
position
and it this is the type of chest that
reminds me
forcibly reminds me how difficult it is
to win a game of chess
h4g4 double rooks white is doing
everything right queen e8
controversial moment with this move king
g2
was this the right move the engine
approved move
in fact as it turns out so fabi is
getting it all together he's he's in the
kitchen he's cooking and so on so on
everything approved and then the move h5
and it all goes to
guess what a draw and after queen
yeah we were before we came on air
my i was looking at the uh move queen
a4 as uh my main move and after queen a4
it was actually
rook d4 and queen takes a6
and it all petered out very quickly
into a draw after rook takes e6
wouldn't you know it but no we did see
the move queen g6
and quickly we got e5 and
on the board and if you take it it looks
like you made it
i get made it how sweet
well even if yeah well here i thought um
well here you just lose the exchange at
the very least i thought king of seven
was the
okay what do we have to show was the way
to show off
yeah off was the style
what's the style king g6 rookie six king
h7g
wait wait wait what's the knight h8 mate
what are you guys doing oh
oh that's funny you made i didn't even
look that direction that is so funny
it's the patterns that we're unfamiliar
with that get us mated
uh knight h8 nice but i like your mate
better
you're you're you're me thank you it's
yeah it's the more professional one
exactly never put nights in
do you play against f4 uh you were
mentioning the game petering out but i
actually
didn't know what's going on because it
there is a chance that
you yeah that you play f5 and play for
the compensation say that king is weak
your pawns are really not going anywhere
and if there's any way that my rook ever
bothers that king it's basically mate
isn't that the real question though how
does your bother that's the question
right
king and if you don't have a good answer
maybe you can't go for this because you
are down a pawn
yeah if you put your rooks on the b file
i've got knight before
i've got the d file and the c file
covered
and by the way for that matter i could
probably get some counter play myself
with rook c2 and rook d2
but it just does look like
my vulnerable king is actually you can't
get
you don't get to play rook f8 mate yep
give me a knight give me a rook
yeah wow but uh i mean it goes to show
how tough
chess is and how tough is chess uh look
at this one
i mean mvl was was nursing
a nice extra pawn there he had his
passport on d6
a long time ago like with four rooks on
the board
it sure looked like he was the one uh
pushing the action i was surprised by
the move queen
i would have gone for the setup with b4
and bishop
and it's over actually right away what
is over
the game is over and you're looking at
right now has just been drawn
has been agreed to a draw because guess
what it's just
light squared bishop dark squared bishop
draw a greed
again how difficult is it to win a game
and what about this game wang hao
and
sasha grisha this was a this was crazy
crazy game uh here he took on d5
uh during the break i was having some
fun with the engine the engine by the
way this is great you're gonna love it
zero zero zero zero zero all the way
through
our look at this as a as a variation
that was uh topical
takes takes now you can't take on e7
because c2 is hanging and after knight
takes d5
so you go bishop e4 and this whole
variation
all the way through the whole thing it
zeros
and even here at zeros after g6
star move
e4 and knight c6 and then after queen e3
check you get a force per pet what was
it like murray's the
boss chair yeah yeah yeah exactly
you straight to the last chair to do not
take your covid test
[Laughter]
but he didn't he didn't play that after
knight f4
the game continued knight takes d5
and are we here knight d4 queen d7 was
played
on the board okay and the funny thing is
that when you play grizzchek
he spends all his time he gets to one
minute
but then it feels like for the next hour
and a half
that minute doesn't move exactly and he
plays incredibly good
mm-hmm and you join him and you
jordan pressure yeah as wang i was doing
now why
i was sitting here going didn't i just
sharpen the game did some sacrifices
made it busy
get my chances wait a second i might i
better be careful i might lose this one
if i'm right but i'm in time pressure
but what is going on because
i like queens they're pretty good chess
pieces
they really are they really are
and uh pawn on e7 once it gets
captured it's only two minor pieces yeah
it's kind of doomed right
black for choice so let's see bishop g6
what on earth oh pardon me queen d7 i
i was going to say c4 bishop
to g6 and what on earth have we got to
show for all of our
pyrotechnics
hey don't all jump out at once
this this was this was not well it's
nice and good but
i'm telling you i don't think he saw
rookie eight i don't think he saw rookie
eight i think he's been
kind of fumbling around after rookie
landed on the board
and we'll find out at a press conference
but i think he missed rookie eight right
here
because since then he has played
what looks like okay knight f4 i don't
know accurate or not i like this move
this is gambling chess what white's been
doing so far is pure gambling
like you hope it works out it's not like
you suddenly won back your piece and you
said
hey look at that see i could easily
prove it no
you're gambling and it looks like it's
going to not pay off as your move
bishop g60 has is on the board yeah well
again
uh so far it's all okay
and this is where bishop takes b6 as
mentioned
queen takes b6 knight d4 in the game
position as we're about to see the
bishop on f2
is beautiful as it is we love bishops
and
it's not doing anything and we really
need
to use the open f file and that was why
in this line we're getting pawns
we've got a rook on the seventh we've
got ideas of rook
to f1 and rook f8 he's not getting
any of that let's take a look at the
solution they are long time let's try to
follow the action
95 takes bishop d5994 queen d7 c4
bishop g6 and quickly wang hao
answer 96 krishuk said no more time for
long thoughts this pawn needs to die i'm
gonna take it with a rook
and rook a1 has been played question is
you got some threats for the next couple
of moves maybe an initiative
for a tempo or two so you need to
win some material as white i think that
if he gets a position with a rook and a
bishop and a pawn for the queen
he'll be very thrilled oh yeah
good luck let's see you got two bishops
sorry you have a bishop and knight
and a pawn for the queen right now i
just need to win an exchange
but i i just don't know if you can get
out yeah i have to figure that out
and it's black's move in this position
right right
the bishop c5 is on tap so let's
play shall we i mean tell me if i'm
doing something wrong here guys let's
play the obvious move bring a rook into
the game
if you do go bishop c5 let me play the
obvious move and
not lose the exchange uh
maybe i can eventually see something
like bishop d4 here
no but i'm hanging yeah no it's okay
yeah it's okay
it's okay uh-huh you're not hanging
because there's f8
yeah let me just show that to everybody
uh
whoops rook f8 background he's played
the mo the most principled move
the most human move especially in time
pressure that you would play
is bishop to f7 yeah ask the question
directly
what are you planning to do with these
pieces right now
kick the knight i agree wholeheartedly
that is the
the most direct most principled so do i
take the tempo and the
pawn on b7 that's not as much as i
wanted to get out of the position i have
to admit
you mean knight c5 that's not the most
juicy oh i'm the pawn grabber whoa whoa
ho ho ho ho
ho ho
what is this what excuse me oh this
should d5 rookie seven and knight f5
who gets made it first queenie for
bishop d4
just slow down slow down you're whoa
whoa i got it we got to look at it
variations right here now could we get
we get the moves on the board so what
we're just saying
mm-hmm but you were mentioning something
else first
no no i'm mentioning this first word
takes d5
no this line must be looked at everybody
wants to know why you can't just take a
free
uh a free piece but it's not free right
at all
yeah so let's not just was pass it this
bishop d4 check and and chris
has been shocked by this move he's down
to he's down
and he didn't finally take on d5 to have
38 seconds left so he was stunned
by knight g7 this line by the way is
great for
for white so this is amazing
shot by wang hao to keep the game alive
nineteen so he takes on d5 i assume rook
takes e7
is forced don't see another move
it looks that way yeah rook takes e7
queen takes d7
i've got this great mate guys just a
little sorry i just have to show you
because it is pretty knight f5 rookie
one
bishop d4 king g8
everybody but the same mate is going to
happen the exact same mate is going to
happen
yeah instead of instead of this line you
could you could take on e7
yeah you take okay technician queen
takes e7
knight f5 and this is the point that i'm
setting it up i'm setting up bishop d4
and knight h6
i don't know if you have a good square
to cover h6
from and you win the d5 pawn back
and you'll end up with bishop knight and
two pawns
for the queen and exposed the king
[Music]
bishop f7 bishop f7 the natural
move allows us uh an incredible shot
knight g7 that was really stunning
indeed oh my you say yes i love your
word visual
g7 in chess we have these moments in the
game
where your opponent hits you with a shot
sorry he's down to 13 seconds
drain drains out of your face and we're
expecting
after we and he's done it he's playing
rookie seven
queenie seven i assume that only move
uh actually you bailed the only move
bishop can you bail playable isn't it
bishop tell me how you bail after knight
f5 queen e4 queen e4 threatening nate
uh bishop give it back d4 queen d4
oh you're gonna get okay then in that
case i'm gonna take your bishop
but i play the pawn to h5
uh no that's not me getting out of but
wait a minute why is that a bail
introduce you down a pawn
in this bailing line i mean you're not a
pawn only if you play rook a1
no oh yes you're right no yeah but
wait a minute oh because you have room
that's a decent bail i mean
it's a pretty decent bail i have to say
right
and by the way when you're watching
grisha's clock go down to 10 seconds
you start looking for those
you know exit plan b uh kind of deals
yeah maybe rook a1 you're upon but
you're not better
exactly i would say that that's very
very good
compensation with the with the bishop
agreed
uh so we're looking at a bale
after knight f5 and he didn't bail he's
like nah
bird he covered h6 i'm chris
what do i need so at the end we've got
same picture we have two minor pieces
two minor pieces
versus a queen we've got a two pawns in
the bucket
and we have a vulnerable king how far
are we from move 40
we're on move 34 so we still c-65 has
moved 40
uh 34. they still got a while yep
but now now they're no and they're both
down to a minute by the way
all right these d6 looks like a decisive
thread right i got these six and you
resign
right so i love it okay i'm gonna that
doesn't stop yeah
that's game i was trying to bail with
nighttime
no bail for me just to jail
um okay do you think this is going to
happen
and you got 40 seconds for this
mess matt i gotta say it's so brave to
play queen f faith
i would not have gone that way not at
all my instinct would have been through
okay queenie
and let's go right he's played the move
h5 h5 maybe
oh he's preparing king h7 against d6
so d6 king h7 knight has the only idea i
can find a queen every
i just want to play just just keep going
i mean who wow
yeah just keep going you're a br that's
a bad
man with this kind of accuracy
i tell you i would not if i'm black i am
sweating
but am i losing rook d8 i understand i i
really would have rather played queenie
i agree and i take and i go king h8 king
h8
force because king 860 as you should
point out loses the knight f5
mate yep it certainly does that's
pretty one but after king h8 you're
telling me i don't have
some stupendous win here i'm i mean you
might
i might you might i'm not saying that
you don't i just
yeah knight g6 fails to queen g6 right
queen g6 no but even that's lost queen
g6
rook g is it lost yeah d4
you're gonna lose both of your pawns on
the other side too i know but
no no i i gotta figure uh
if that's the best the the trick of
course is if you took with the rook
i wanted the discovery but you're right
you could
at least kick 97 on the board
we're getting the line seven sorry
and there's still not a time control yet
four moves
is it four ninety seven queen eight four
moves left to go
a small update guys i think
the game between fabiano carona and
dingleran will finish in a draw
there is a tacit draw offer as dingleran
has made a three-month repetition
huh yes he has you're right and
time is not a big factor there no
they've reached mu 40 now so
fabi has plenty of time to think about
it all right enough of this let's go
back to the grister game
by the way the big winner of the day of
course jan napoleonicity because
he just separated himself by a point
from everyone
right his rivals were sitting at
three at a half a point behind we were
saying oh it's
everybody's ball game anybody's ball
game he's gonna get a full rest day
to get his mind right knowing that he's
got a full point
on the field with four rounds to go
and figure out his strategy to get to
that podium at the end of this that's a
huge
huge result for him this game does not
have any bearing on the leadership
leaderboard whatsoever but it's not a
game
like it could be the game of the
tournament look at this guys
he didn't go for the rook f5 rip g5 rook
g7 maneuver
instead he's playing a complete
positional
move he wants to play knight f5 knight
is a big threat here
yeah but it means that he's going to
bother him
oh rook d6 just oh but i thought he was
going to play bishop to e5
to kind of keep a positional dominance
the queen can't move
because of rook f7 and it will be
checkmate so the queen is locked in
maybe rook d7 you don't have a way to ah
and fabia has drawn against dingler and
big news it's official oh is
yeah nepalnyatra's team happy or what
oh what a round for nepo fans that was
huge as this game ended up in
a repetition and mvl's game
ended up draw so tournament
leader got got a separation maurice that
extra half point
that's very useful in these candidate
tournaments where millions of dollars to
play for
definitely a huge result he played the
lowest rated player in the competition
and defeated him didn't he beat him in
the first half as well no no
on the contrary kirill was winning in a
french with a brilliant sacrifice that
he missed on the king side
it was very difficult with this rook
double rook left on the king said it was
almost impossible to see
especially because kira was in a lot of
time pressure but actually nepal
suffered against alexenko in the first
half
so he so he got his revenge and we see
here rook d6
has been played in the game and this one
is just a bishop brook and pawn in a way
that the queen
is guaranteed to survive we're not
afraid if we're
if we have black here but you're not
afraid of your white either
no i'm just thinking it's a fortress
maurice i think white is going to play
f3 rook f4 and say draw a greek
drug yeah i don't think the queen could
overcome
no i think the rook i totally agree yeah
it's just it's just
position and despite all the
pyrotechnics
we saw earlier may have even been
winning
at one point but bishop f7 the most
human move you can name
i've got to go back g7
no it's just craziness like wow
maybe bishop f5 is more accurate here if
you want to eject this knight
yeah so let's do not allow knight g7 not
allow knight g7
because but we never really answered the
question
about rook a8 right we didn't find an
actual
problem with it like rookie 1 88
that that would have been my move just
on principles i'd like to get my pieces
into the game and
yeah i agree once you see bishop f7 and
bishop f5 and say
eviction notice get that knight on e6
out makes sense
but rookie 8 also might have been
advantage
black but it was this moment this is an
amazing moment after bishop f7 that
wang hao gets to uncork a move we dream
of
knight takes g7 it's beautiful it with
with the concept that king takes
and your king walks into deadly
fire uh after bishop d4 could rookie
might be met
could ricky have been met by bishop a7
i'm just gonna play a stupid move
wow that's ambitious well right you know
i'm just
i'm just playing according to the
minuses you give me so you would
defend the pawn what happens if i take
it
well now uh ideas of bishop f7 and by
the way guys
the game has been drawn officially not a
big surprise at that point right this
fourth year
quite obvious clear fortress right at
the very end
yeah we were wondering yeah i want to
see that i actually want to see this
move
so rook a e8 we were analyzing bishop
takes a7 if we can go back to the board
yeah i want to check that out bring us
back there uh
right here we were looking at this move
as an alternative to bishop f7 marie
says give me the pawn
to me the training is paying off look at
this
i'm not i'm not following your pawn
rubber style
yes you are you're you're moved
undefended upon so
take it it's not a move i like to play
that's for sure but the question is if i
play bishop f7
or bishop f5 which which do you prefer
but bishop oh excuse me i apologize
you're right the bishop got out of the
way with bishop takes a7
okay bishop seven i no longer have any
kind of straightforward jimmies
here nice you do have five that's a
tempo against the queen
that could be useful maurice yeah yeah
yeah
i agree but we have a
guest with us today what a special
appearance we have
maxim vashir lagrav maxim
it seems like you put some pressure on
today but it wasn't quite enough
good morning i also made smoking
it still is bright and early
um yeah well thank you for for having me
it was like i thought i had a great
position
but i assume i didn't make the most of
it
at what point did you think yeah this
one i'm i'm
trying i'm trying i'm putting pressure
where do you think
it started to go wrong i don't know
maybe in einstein
quinito was not a great move but
i just felt like i had this great
position and
but somehow i didn't make it work so
i mean it's strange to me that the
computer even thinks i'm better here
because
i thought i should be careful already
i'm not really careful with the white
pieces because of this powerful
before break yeah exactly
it's like i played with c4 exactly to
avoid
before
maxim round one i don't want to break
bad memories but round one a big novelty
played against you
and then round two you were struggling
and managed
to draw that game do you feel like
today's game had to be something that
settled down the ship get the mind right
get yourself back in flow
well i just wanted things to click
together
so that you know i could start playing
i will chess from start to finish and
well i
don't feel like i played a bad game
today definitely but
i would have opt for a little more at
the end
but i don't know in general i mean i've
i've had good moments in the first two
games as well so
i'm trying also not to focus on the
negative also i mean that
that two games meant i needed to to
change a few things
in my play uh so also
good things uh boss against fabiano and
then against uh
think lyran but um
of course i'm hoping for the free day uh
to be productive and
to to come up uh with
uh better state of mind and at least
play
at various like i played today
we definitely want to see you with
quality chess
tell us how you feel seeing the
leader separate himself a little bit
from you guys
he was under a lot of pressure with half
a point uh lead
it's not very much but now it's
increased do you feel that
round the clock is ticking and a point
is a lot
one point is a lot but at the same time
there's still four games to play we
still have opportunities
uh to catch up with jan and
things are gonna that get ten things are
gonna get clutch so
it's hard to say what's gonna happen
next
of course he's a favorite i mean there's
no there's no denying that
right but we know that you're france's
favorite and
that you've shown that you can win in
some crucial crucial games
i still have to say that despite the
loss the way that you handle the opening
in that favi game was just all just
inspiring
like how are you able to find and
calculate the way out of
such a difficult novelty to face over
the board
well you know i tried before the event
to
be ready for such situations because of
course
you know novelties can happen but um
you know the general assessment is
not that black is losing by force so
that means there should be a way out and
i just took the time to to find my way
out and maybe
the problem was that i relaxed a little
bit early when i thought
so the door cleared over
again uh uh mvl not to
uh hit a point too hard but in that
table-based ending of the rook
versus the night did you have an
awareness that it was
potentially a draw
i thought it should be a an easier draw
than it actually was
and i underestimated the fact that the
pawn on g2 was changing
a lot of things i even thought about
for a second obviously bringing my
knight to g7 but i thought it was
too passive and i couldn't find um
a breakthrough with my knight on h6 but
there was this beautiful silk swank that
fabiano managed to put into place
very good yeah because we were having
this difficulty
in guessing if your cells
were knowledgeable about that table but
base ending because
alejandro did know it was a draw from an
article he had read by paul benko so
he was he was lording over us
his great knowledge of this ending and
he was right
and it looked like you almost got away
no i mean i expected it to be a draw but
i didn't know the actual best way
okay fair enough well maxine thank you
so much
for joining us enjoy your rest day
you are giving us a thrill in this army
want to
keep seeing you play amazing chess good
luck
in the rest of your games thank you very
much
good luck good luck
and after round 10 this is our current
standings
he is so happy today wrestling tomorrow
and he goes into it with a full point
instead of a half point lead
and those three hungry players
they are feeling the pressure now
another round has
passed and the lead has increased mvl
fabiano carolina and
all of them at five and a half points
out of ten they're the only people with
realistic chances of
catching yoni ponnyachi and they're
gonna have to do it well
rather soon unless mvl pulls off a nice
win
in the last round as he'll be facing
against jan in
uh round number 14. of course
we are uh followed by wang hao and
gristrok with four and a half
and dingleran uh catches kyola alexenko
so he's not
dead last anymore but with very
difficult maybe
impossible chances i would say
impossible chances
to catch uh the leaders at the top guys
what a tournament we've had
drama being added but jan he can't be so
happy about this
remember no round tomorrow the next
round will be game 11 on april 23rd
on april 24th we will have game 12.
another rest day after that and the
tournament finishes
on the 26th and the 27th with the
unlikely scenario of playoffs
the pairings oh wow oh wow
what around this door what do we have in
store
will fabi feel the pressure to score
with black he will have the black pieces
against jan ne pomnyacci
he has a point behind but remember this
is very similar to the situation that he
was against
mvl in which he needed to win the
difference black is not easy to play at
this level
these are professional chess players and
white repertoires can be quite solid
alexenko against wong hao perhaps not
the most interesting for the standings
but still an important game krishuk
against mvl
a similar situation for mvl when does he
want to start striking wins
he has two whites left and two blacks
left will he try to push against chris
and his uh eternal time pressure finally
giri with white he does have a chance to
get to push against
ding loren will that happen we've uh
seen dingler and being extremely solid
today he played a really nice game
against fabiano carolina
very even all throughout even though
both sides did try
to make it complicated it wasn't like an
easy dead draw he just played good chess
and got the draw it's round 11 is gonna
be
crucial for this tournament guys
looking forward to it i mean it was
really nice
guys we've had three great rounds to
start the second half i hope everybody
who's joined us
uh will continue to do so and look
forward
not to the rest day tomorrow but the day
thereafter on friday yeah that's right
join us then and
we'll see you in two days good night
[Music]
everyone
[Music]
you